In the 19th century,...
...a sturdier weapon called the epee was introduced.
I would say for a first-time viewer of fencing,...
...the easier one to see is epee.
That's because it's the slowest of the three events...
...due to the whole body being a target area.
Fencers are more hesitant to initiate an attack,...
...exposing their whole body to their opponent.
It is also the only of the three weapons...
...where the right of way rule is not enforced.
What's the right of way?
Well, in a classic duel,...
...the only way to win if you're being attacked is to parry...
...or deflect your opponent's weapon and then riposte...
...or attack your opponent.
With the epee, simultaneous hits can occur...
...and both fencers will receive a point.
And now the fastest event, the sabre.
The sabre is the second fastest sport in the Olympic Games...
...after the rifle shooting.
That means the blade is moving almost as fast as a bullet.
Instead of just thrusting,...
...the sabre fencers can score on any part of the upper body...
...with slashes and thrust.
And because the right of way is enforced,...
...sabre fencers are more incentivized to attack first.